déferlement en bavière des milliers
d'allemands de l'est passent la
frontière autrichienne et hongroise
ouvertes la nuit dernière la santé les
françaises ne va pas trop mal merci les
augmentations inquiétantes des suicides
qui pue plus que la route
la grève chez peugeot le mouvement
bursite à mulhouse mais n'en fait pas
son show d'affaires des gorilles rebondi
comme l'avait annoncé le juge
d'instruction lucelle vilma et sa femme
entendue cet après midi par les
gendarmes
monsieur bonsoir ce n'est pas la
réunification pas encore c'est déjà la
réunion par milliers d allemands venus
de l'est ranime et résolvent à leur
manière la fameuse question allemande
dont les chancelleries et les experts
débattent avec précaution depuis 40 ans
eux les réfugiés ou les faux vacanciers
qui depuis des semaines attendait en
hongrie e déferle sur les camps de
transit
installé en bavière la frontière entre
la hongrie et l'autriche est ouverte
depuis hier soir minuit
d'abord les faits bruno le dreff la
liberté et le bonheur
désormais ils sont allemands de l'ouest
le tout nouveau passeport qu'ils
brandissent en fait foi
depuis 3 heures du matin c'est un flot
ininterrompu en voiture à pied entre à
moto ils sont des centaines bientôt des
milliers on parle de 6000 puis de 10000
immigrants la plus grosse vague
d'allemands de l'est depuis la
construction du mur de berlin il y avait
28 ans la hongrie a ouvert ses
frontières il s'y engouffre pour la
première fois un pays du pacte de
varsovie aide les ressortissants d'une
nation communiste à passer à l'ouest
il traverse l'autriche direction l'autre
allemagne
là on procède à l échange des passeports
ils deviennent citoyens de l'ouest et
reçoivent 50 marques
certains sont accueillis par leurs
familles pour les autres de gigantesque
camp de transit
ils n'y resteront pas là
plupart de ces réfugiés ont entre 20 et
30 ans et possède une solide formation
c'est toute une force de travail qui bat
à l'ouest
alors pourquoi cet exode volontaire il
ya sûrement l'espoir d'une vie meilleure
les images aussi de liberté et de luxe
que transmet la télévision malgré le mur
et puis il ya le choc de ces réformes de
ce changement de mentalité qui
transforme l'union soviétique et
certains pays naissent à l'exception
caricaturale de l'allemagne de l'est
figé sous la poigne d'un necker mourant
ses motivations cet espoir philippe
rochot les uns senti en accompagnant
vers leur nouvelle vie un groupe
d'étudiants qu'il a rencontrés à la
frontière
ce radio cassette est l'objet le plus
précieux que christa ait pu sortir
d'allemagne de l'est avec son compagnon
rendent c'est sa camarade d'école
catarina ils ont attendu un mois en
hongrie la peur au ventre
il redoutait que le gouvernement ne les
oblige à retourner dans leur pays
le passage de la frontière entre
l'autriche et l'allemagne c'est
l'aboutissement d'un voyage qu'ils ont
préparé depuis deux ans avec cette
vieille trabant le modèle de voiture
pratiquement unique que fabrique
l'allemagne de l'est
de rompre définitivement avec
l'allemagne socialiste en cassant sa
plaque allemagne démocratique pour
laisser simplement le nez de deutschland
qui marque les voitures en allemagne
fédérale voulaient plus être un citoyen
est-allemand pourquoi on va répondre
j'ai trop rêvé de voyager de liberté je
suis électricien
j'ai toujours espéré travailler sur des
chantiers mais c'était impossible
maintenant ça va marcher nous
engraissons clac première ville
d'accueil la petite cité de ville sauf
un en bavière
déjà 200 voitures d'allemagne de l'est
sont arrivés
il va falloir chercher un appartement
pas trop cher aussi une cuisine on a
abandonné le nôtre là-bas dans la
nouvelle vie de christa et de rendre
tout reste à faire mais ils sont
persuadés de trouver un travail
astorg vos premières impressions sur
l'allemagne fédérale
c'est super on se réjouit vraiment
d'être enfin arrivé qu'est ce qui vous a
le plus frappé depuis que vous êtes là
l'accueil des gens qui nous saluent
depuis leur voiture
avis aux fans voilà quinze jours qu'on
était prêt pour l'accueil des réfugiés
1200 comme christa et ses amis sont
venus avec leur voiture personnelle ce
qui arrive par autobus ou par trains
spéciaux iront dans d'autres camps de
toile celui ci est déjà plein c'est pas
grave on y revient le jour allez vous
rester lire ça donne
je ne sais pas je ne sais même pas ce
qu'on va faire
christa et ses amis feront ici valider
leur passeport et recevront des
autorités allemandes 50 marques 150
francs mais les citoyens d'allemagne
fédérale ont été priées de bien les
accueillir et de les aider à trouver du
travail nous a affirmé que des milliers
d'autres jeunes de 25 ans comme elle
profiterait de la première occasion
comme celle des voyages en hongrie pour
passer à l'ouest et venir les rejoindre
en allemagne fédérale
oui pour la première fois donc dans
l'histoire du pacte de varsovie la
hongrie ouvre la brèche qu'elle avait
déjà ébauché en mai dernier en dès
maintenant les barbelés qui la séparait
de l'autriche à berlin est la presse se
contente de répéter la réaction
officielle qui est sèche et curieusement
formulé changement que oui elle est même
vraiment puisque l' agence est-allemande
de presse adn écrit que la hongrie s'est
engagé dans un trafic organisé d'êtres
humains rien de moins alors en revanche
qui est très intéressant c'est qu'il n'y
a pas de commentaire du tout jusqu'à
présent à moscou les officiels
soviétique adoptant l'attitude seul à
faire des hongrois se ne nous regarde
pas j'ai l'impression que le geste dont
voici un petit peu la politique
étrangère de monsieur gorbatchev dans la
mesure où les allemands de l'ouest
conforté dans l'idée que ça va de mieux
en mieux entre l'est et l'ouest vont
vouloir que le désarmement nucléaire de
l'occident s'accélère ce qui est un des
bus prioritaires de monsieur gorbatchev
justement quant à la hongrie bat la
grille on l'a dit mais évidemment
qu'elle devait faire une bonne affaire
car on imagine mal que économiquement
parlant financièrement parlant les
allemands de l'ouest ne se montre pas un
petit peu reconnaissants crise mais on
ya quelques années il semble en revanche
la grève à avoir des rapports difficiles
avec ses voisins à ses alliés des pays
du pacte de varsovie
car des pays comme par exemple la
tchécoslovaquie la bulgarie de la
bulgarie la roumanie ne tiennent pas du
tout à ce que leurs ressortissants
passent eux aussi à l'ouest à leur tour
à travers cette passoire hongroise donc
on peut imaginer que la hongrie qui
ouvre sa frontière vers l'ouest va se
trouver bloqué par
espèce de cordon sanitaire que ces pays
ami et allié aux principes vont établir
à son encontre
et justement en tchécoslovaquie il ya
quelques 400 réfugiés est-allemand qui
occupent l'ambassade de mode mais bien
il est évident qu'ils n'ont pour
l'instant aucun espoir de sortir depuis
la nuit dernière en allemagne fédérale
on applaudit on klaxonne sa joie on
accueille les réfugiés
imaginons chez nos voisins chez ce
peuple déchiré et romantique le sens des
images que nous venons de voir ses
cousins ses proches qui arrive
aujourd'hui et qui en précède d'autres
monsieur serait plaire bonsoir vous êtes
le porte parole du conseil de l'europe à
strasbourg
vous êtes allemand vous êtes né à l'est
vous êtes passé vous à l'ouest des 47
alors pour vous cette journée est ce que
vous en rêviez depuis depuis 42 ans
oui d'abord une petite correction il en
mange peut pas me prononcer ici qu'on
porte parole du conseil de l'europe mais
qu'on peut voir les tms propre
expérience et je vous dis tout de suite
que je suis et poursuit les images et
toutes les nouvelles avec le coup
d'émotion
et bien justement à ces émotions me
rappelle mon propre passage de l'est ont
autrefois c'est d'un corps la zone
occupée par l'union soviétique vers
l'ouest
et là vous vous attendiez à voir autant
de gens passer comme ça d'un seul coup
vous avez quand on ne poussez pas cette
volonté de liberté des vivants liberté
que c'est aussi de trouver les propres
épreuves ainsi qu'à l'âge qu'on ne près
de tout faire évidemment pendant cette
époque là
après 47 c'était la première grande
vainqueur allemand qui quittaient
l'allemagne de l'est
c'était tout à fait autre chose on avec
on a vécu cette volonté de liberté auto
fin aujourd'hui c'est différent parce
qu'il trouve un système déjà en place en
allemagne fédérale alors que je défends
en allemagne fédérale 1 on comprend bien
sûr l'émotion des allemands de l'ouest
est ce qu'il n'ya pas déjà un peu
d'inquiétude parce que ces gens qui sont
jeunes pour la plupart y vont
ni reprendre des emplois ils vont
bousculer certaines habitudes
vous savez bien sûr on se pose des
questions il faut trouver de dix ans un
règlement il faut trouver de dix ans de
possibilités mais je crois ce que je
peux lire dans la presse sur
l'inquiétude médiatique beaucoup plus
grande que la réalité finalement ça va
s'intégrer facilement
n'oublions pas que nous ont l'habitude
de vivre avec des réfugiés
je suis parti à 47 la première mouvance
le premier mouvement après il ya
d'autres avant la construction du mur
après la consule mais il y avait
toujours de réfugiés on a l'habitude
alors justement monsieur je préfère d'un
mot et dieu sait si la question est
complexe à votre avis c'est un premier
pas vers une forme de réunification
ce qui fit dire vous savez que la
réunification des êtres humains c'est
déjà un grand avantage chez soi dans ce
sens là il faut je me contenterai
actuellement c'était une belle formule
monsieur sinclair je vous remercie
merci la sphère grégory voici longtemps
que ce sinistre ans à sina com il ya
près de cinq ans n'avait plus fait la
une les titres des journaux
hier soir le juge simon qui instruit la
sphère depuis plus de deux ans le juge
simon sortait de son silence et
annonçait à paul lefèvre sur l'a52
prochains rebondissements et bien nous y
voici
michel villemin et son épouse ont été
entendus aujourd'hui par les gendarmes
il avait levé schaller nouveau
rebondissement après la rupture hier du
silence par le juge michel le frère de
jean marie villemin a été entendu
aujourd'hui avec son épouse dans les
vosges par les gendarmes de la section
de recherches de dijon
autant dire sur commission rogatoire du
juge simon qui a repris l'affairé en
main un travail minutieux qui lui a fait
arpenter la vallée de la vologne
durant des mois et il semble que sa
conviction s'éloigne de la culpabilité
de christine villemin qui est pourtant
inculpée de l'assassinât de son fils
depuis le printemps 1985 elle libre et
assigné à résidence dans l'essonne où
elle habite avec son mari jean marie lui
est inculpé d'avoir assassiné son cousin
bernard laroche
on attend l'issue de l'enquète sur
grégory pour juger ces faits là bernard
laroche est mort d'avoir été le premier
suspect de la sphère inculpé par le juge
lambert puis relâchés sans être disculpé
faut dire qu'il avait été accusé par sa
jeune belle-soeur muriel d'être allé
chercher le petit grégory muriel qui
s'étaient rétractés à l'époque est
aujourd'hui majeure elle a été entendue
par le juge simon à plusieurs reprises
la veuve de bernard laroche marie-ange
aujourd'hui remariée se bat toujours
pour que l'on reconnaisse l'innocence de
son mari défunt
mais il semble à lire entre les lignes
des déclarations surprise du juge
estimant qu'au contraire la conviction
judiciaire en face l'assassin du petit
grégory
le conflit continue chez peugeot les
usines de sochaux n'est toujours pas
touché mais à mulhouse il ya eu des
échauffourées ton ce matin entre
grévistes et non grévistes et le climat
c'est plutôt tendue maryse mano ce matin
la journée commence dans un climat tendu
un blues
les grévistes qui défilent dans les
ateliers se heurte à des cadres non
régis bousculade
le ton monte mais il n'y aura pas
d'incident grave et d'ailleurs la cgeci
déclare un peu plus tard entre et
passivement dans le conflit à la
japonaise
un badge sur la poitrine malgré les
espoirs des syndicats l'arrivée de la
seconde équipe cet après-midi n'amplifie
pas le mouvement sit in dans les
ateliers demande de négociations une
chose est sûre
près de la moitié de la production a été
assurée vendredi dernier les chaînes
étaient totalement arrêtées
de même le voyage des ouvriers de
mulhouse à sochaux n'a pas eu lieu
sochaux où malgré le renfort de la cfdt
les débrayages semble limité
oui et selon la fédération des
travailleurs de la métallurgie cgt la
direction pratique chez peugeot la
méthode rocard et joue le pourrissement
fin de citation policiers et gendarmes
réunis sur le front de la grogne et des
revendications salariales tout au long
de cette semaine du côté des policiers
confrontation syndical du côté des
gendarmes réunion de concertation rémy
roche paradoxaux piquant cinq camions
qui devait véhiculer dans les rues de
paris le mécontentement des policiers de
lui et c'est ce sont finalement retrouvé
à la fourrière un nouveau signe de
crispation à 48 heures de la rencontre
du syndicat avec le ministre de
l'intérieur au programme de l'entrevue
les dossiers désormais brûlant des
salaires
du déroulement de carrière c'est tout un
ensemble de fonctionnement interne la
police nationale qui est à revoir de
fond en cours d'ailleurs bon je crois
que l'erreur qui a été commise
ce n'est pas d'avoir mené parallèlement
au plan de modernisation en 1985 une
réorganisation des structures et les
corps de la police nationale déterminez
lui aussi bernard deleu place le patron
de la phase ii majoritaire nous allons
rencontrer pierre joxe
si le compte n'y est pas nous passerons
à l'action avertissait-il ce matin sur
antenne 2 les gendarmes peu après la
grogne entre en phase de réflexion comme
promis par jean pierre chevènement après
la grande réunion du 23 août
cinq commissions dans cinq villes et 87
gendarmes choisi au hasard pour plancher
sur les réformes concrètes que tous dans
la hiérarchie estime aujourd'hui
indispensable au terme de quatre jours
de débats un rapport sera rédigé pour
être remis avant la fin du mois au
ministre de la défense dignité et
sobriété
madame simone veil a commenté ce matin
au micro d'yves mourousi sur rmc les
propos antisémites du vieux cinéaste
autant-lara écoutant madame veil
milliards qui n'a pas qui tu veux tu te
paraît-il toujours méchant qui n'a pas
eu le succès dans les dernières années
qu'ils pouvaient espérer on connaissait
réaction moment la nouvelle vague et qui
est devenu de plus en plus aigri vous
savez on dit quelquefois que la
vieillesse est un naufrage il ya des
choses que vis-à-vis des morts on n'a
pas le droit de laisser parler vis-à-vis
de nos camarades qui sont ma vie à mes
parents mon père de ma mort de mon frère
de mon oncle mon cousin
nous n'avons pas le droit de nous a
reproché aux juifs d'avoir été lâche de
ne pas voir de nous être laissée mener à
l'abattoir
donc comme on réagit son vis-à-vis des
fauries cioni c'est parce que nous ne
pouvons pas ne pas réagir
en même temps je n'en parle pas beaucoup
ils soient mes enfants je peux pas leur
en parlez pas c'est peut-être alors on
est nouveau piéger
moi je pensais que la presse avoir vécu
ça je pourrais vivre comme tout le monde
tranquillement strasbourg tout à l'heure
c'est debout que tous les députés
européens ont acclamé madame simone veil
tous les députés à l'exception de ceux
de l'extrême droite
et c'est jean claude martinez qui va
remplacer autant lara au parlement de
strasbourg il n'aura donc pas perdu son
argent il avait payé 500 mille francs
avait-il dit
même pour figurer sur la liste du front
national le premier ministre michel
rocard a dit aujourd'hui au président de
tanzanie son indignation au sujet des
massacres qui ont ensanglanté en afrique
du sud dans la région du cap
les dernières élections après demain au
cap
une manifestation aura lieu pour
dénoncer la répression au premier rang
aux côtés de monseigneur tout ou une
personnalité inattendue un blanc le
maire du cap martin laroche joubert et à
l'ins l'ont rencontré l'homme qui crée
le choc aujourd'hui à l'afrique du sud
pour la première fois le maire d'une
grande ville le cap conduire à une
marche de protestation devant le
parlement contre les violences de
l'apartheid
mercredi prochain bordeaux oliver sera à
côté de l'archevêque noir desmond tout
où malgré l'interdiction de cette
manifestation par la police
une position courageuse et risquer des
troubles éclatent pendant deux semaines
les stations et si certains d'entre nous
sont bien je pense que c'est un tout
petit prix à payer
beaucoup de gens dans cette ville ont
payé davantage et ce prix là où nous
devons payer
avez vous peur je voudrais dire je suis
nerveux je n'ai jamais été appliquée
lors ce genre de choses et je n'ai pas
peur des conséquences
je n'ai pas peur de rester une nuit en
prison ou bien de passer devant la
justice gouv autant se fait sur livret
on suit sur ya beaucoup de gens qui me
soutiennent
cet après midi dans une township on
enterrait une victime des violences du
mercredi 6 septembre jour des élections
des funérailles très politique la haine
c'est le mouvement anti apartheid
interdit est accueilli dans l'église
tandis que reprend le refrain
notre seul péché est la couleur de notre
peau
comment on va la santé pas si mal
répondant des français claude est un le
ministre commentait cet après midi le
rapport qu'il avait demandées sur ce
thème aux experts c'est notre santé
collective s'améliore les maladies
cardiovasculaires restent la première
cause de décès en france et puis ces
deux aggravation dont il est urgent de
prendre conscience
d'abord la progression mortel des
cancers du poumon si vous fumez encore
vraiment attention à cette forme-là de
suicide
et puis l'autre suicide celui du
désespoir ou du mal de vivre qui fait
plus de victimes que les accidents de la
route
alain labouze et yvan barbe l'ont
vérifié à l'hôpital cochin à paris
ils y ont passé la journée dans ce
service d'urgence en psychiatrie la
moitié des vies est occupé par des
personnes qui ont voulu mourir ici
la seule chose qui compte rétablir le
dialogue lui ces genres trois fois il a
tenté de se suicider en se jetant sous
un métro ou en avalant des médicaments
la dernière fois il est arrivé dans ce
service de réanimation
il était dans le coma je m'en souviens
pas je suis arrivé dans une bâche
c'est police secours chapeau qu'ils
demandent c'est pas important la mort
pour moi c'est naze
comment ça c'est important je suis tout
à fait ça ne représente vraiment rien
c'est quitter ce qu'on n'aime pas c'est
parce qu'ils étaient qu'on aime le
chercher n'importe quoi pour me suicider
après la rénovation nous ne laissons pas
tomber ce genre de malade
ils sont pris en charge éventuellement
par d'espèces des services spécialisés
qui vont s'occuper de leurs problèmes
psychologiques
quand les personnes qui ont pris des
médicaments sont découvertes à temps on
les sauve aujourd'hui plus de neuf fois
sur dix avant c'est l inverse une fois
sur 10 elle mourrait de penser au moins
dormir et ne jamais pu revenir puis est
bonne on sait tous pourquoi parce que
rien n'était réglé une tentative de
suicide doit toujours être comprise
comme un appel et je crois qu'il est
important de l'entendre
faute de quoi bon on risque d'aller vers
des récidives ou vers des situations qui
l enisa souffrance du sujet la tentative
de suicide la ts comme on dit ici à
l'hôpital est encore trop souvent une
maladie honteuse
pourtant pour qu'une tentative ne se
transforme pas un jour en suicide
il faut avant tout que les équipes
soignantes soient formés pour savoir
écouter
voir le patient il n'arrive pas toujours
à dire à sa famille des problèmes qui
existent ou alors aux médecins non plus
parce que au psychiatre aussi le
psychiatre fait peur parce que bon c'est
un peu la folie la maladie mentale
c'est c'est difficile d'exprimer
psychiatre souvent ce que ce qu'ils
ressentent
oui c'est souvent nous qui sommes le
moyen de transmission entre la famille
le psychiatre le médecin il ya des gens
qui sont spécialement jamais été
simplement j'étais toujours avec des
gens qui ne comprenaient pas où des gens
qui ne me plaisait pas et c'est tout
mais être seulement gm était seulement
la solitude quand elle devient
meurtrière atteint surtout les personnes
âgées pour les jeunes nous disent
froidement toutes les études c'est le
manque de dialogue et de tolérance qui
parfois les tuent et puis cette nouvelle
plutôt bonne qui confirme l'inégalité
des sexes n'a durée de vie est
maintenant d'un peu plus de 80 ans pour
les femmes
72 ans pour les hommes il y a un siècle
était de 47 ans et de 38 en état
stationnaire télé le bulletin à
laconique est toujours alarmant que
répètent depuis hier soir l'hôpital de
la timone à marseille au sujet de nîmes
enyo 2 le torero français grièvement
blessé hier en arles il souffre d'un
grave traumatisme du rachis cervical il
est paralysé
francis maroteaux christian montcouquiol
35 ans d'inhumer lieu de victimes d'un
toro de miura hier après-midi à la feria
d'arles victimes de l'adversaire le plus
terrible que l'on puisse rencontrer dans
une arène
au mieux on apprend vite
par exemple à victor mendes prétend
qu'il ne faut jamais faire au mieux à
deux fois la même chose et semis ou là
une attaque étrange il charge la
moulette à le drap rouge mais dévisse à
tête parce qu'il voit l'homme il a
compris mais il a compris trop vite trop
tôt
bizarre
les mines ou là sont d'origine andalouse
prête ses lignes mais surtout ils ont
une histoire
c'est un minou là par exemple qui a tué
le célèbre manolete avec ses cornes plus
large que n'importe quel autre toro et
puis un milieu où la ce a réfléchi dès
son entrée dans l'arène et surtout ils
n'attaquent jamais franchement
enfin autre caractéristique son coût
très long qui lui permet le balayage
latéral dont humaine y 2 a été
finalement victime hier après midi elle
me oissel le nom de l'élevage dans
proviennent ces taureaux la grève de la
faim danis nakache et d'autres
informations brèves en france et à
l'étranger avec un ponsinet anis
naccache en grève de la faim depuis
vendredi selon son avocat maître vergès
nakache veut être regroupés avec les
membres de son commando avant d'être
libéré comme l'ont promis
selon lui deux gouvernements français il
est condamné à perpétuité pour sa
tentative d'assassinât de chapour
bakhtiar ou 80
mouloud hamrouche 46 ans nouveau premier
ministre algérien jusqu'à présent et
depuis 86 secrétaire général de la
présidence
il annonce des réformes mais ce qui me
prématurée la participation au
gouvernement de personnes extérieures au
fln dont il est membre
onze ans de prison pour michaela rôdeur
l'infirmière ouest allemande reconnue
coupable aujourd'hui d'avoir tué six ces
malades dont un par négligence dans cet
hôpital de wuppertal verdict jugé trop
clément par la salle mais la cour
reconnaît des circonstances atténuantes
à l'infirmière qui déclare avoir agi par
compassion
greg lemond signe chez head un contrat
de trois ans pour le vainqueur du tour
de france et champion du monde 89 un
contrat de 55 millions de francs
record absolu pour un cycle i
aujourd'hui à la bourse de paris baisse
de l'indicateur de tendance -0 19% en
revanche hausse + dollars à 6 francs 73
contre six francs 66 ans voit un jeune
aristocrate russe une belle italienne
une sulfureuse comtesse des eaux
printanières nous entraîne dans un
torrent de passion et de beauté il
s'agit du dernier film de gergy ce que
milowski que certains ont pu voir à
cannes il sort cette semaine en salles
et d'après nicole cornu langlois ivre
c'est superbe nastassja kinski elle a
compté ce russe marya paulo hoff
perverse et frivole valeria golino et la
naïve et pur djemaa rosselli pâtissière
à mayence toutes deux rivales pour
l'amour de timothy hutton
mais dans la vie elles sont tout à fait
complices ils sont fines cette histoire
de nous surtout en suisse
ce tome 1 qui ont porté voir la personne
de sa vie j'aimerais il donnerait sa vie
pour elle en dirait au début d'un coup
et un autre personne d'un tout changer
d'un coup a toujours dit gemma qui
pointent maintenant c'est toi or c'est
quoi l'amour
vaste question universelle tourgueniev
d'abord puis skolimowski en l'adaptant
en propose une version romantique et
passionnelle qui permet à chacun de
retrouver ou révélé une part de sa vie
j'ai cette passion je sais pas s'il
passe c'est loin pour être dépassée en
dessous de femmes qui aiment et et même
quand tu souffres quand tu aimes quand
même tu te sens tu te sens c'est beau
quand même un peu souffrir jusqu'au bout
mais tu sais c'est c'est beau il n'ya
plus là y'a rien de mauvais qui sort les
deux fins qui se rencontrent c'est un
amour qui n'est pas seul adjectif ne
sont pas les ou oprah tanière mais les
orages de septembre qui se sont abattues
sur plusieurs régions du sud la nuit
dernière et aussi en bretagne alors
demain sophie davant encore des grêlons
ont il y aura encore quelques orages
demain crise qui me feront quand même
moins forts que ceux que nous avons
connus aujourd'hui
il est quatre ont surtout sur la
bretagne sur la façade est du pays
entre les deux un temps brumeux mais
plutôt enseigner je vous en ai un petit
peu plus total et après la pub alors
avons encore avec les pronostics de
pierrette brès pour le kerser de demain
à longchamp le premier tiercé qui comme
tous les mardis se prêtera dorénavant à
ce nouveau jeu qui s'appelle quinté+
donc regardez écoutez bien les
pronostics donc le 8 le 4 le 6 le 13 le
5 le 1 le 10 et le 12
voilà à 23h30 très exactement henri
sannier vous présentera notre dernier
journal demain à partir de 6h30
télématin avec gérard morin et françois
pencher qui recevra pour les quatre
vérités
alain peyrefitte de retour de chine
merci d'avoir suivi ce journal dans
notre nouveau décor imaginé par michel
millecamps est mise au point par bernard
caux et beaucoup d'autres merci pour
votre fidélité très bonne soirée et à
demain 20 heures
à